this is disturbing we've got I saw your
story I find the scary monster being
yeah that a lot of a lot of patients
feel that way and let me explain to you
a little bit what we're talking about
and it's kind of confusing so stick with
me I promise it'll make sense the goal
of the pharmaceutical industry is that
they want to know when you see an ad
does that mean you go fill a
prescription for that drug are those ads
effective at all
that's the question they're trying to
answer and because if they find out
they're effective on you then they want
to send you more then we say ah this
person our ads work on them let's send
them more this someone we can influence
we have real demand that's the goal so
this is how they do it so they'll send
out an ad campaign to let's say a
hundred thousand people if one of those
people sees to add and then let's say
mark Compton goes to pharmacy and says
okay I'm going to get that heartburn
medication you go to the pharmacy pick
up the medication a record is now
created at the pharmacy that you got
that medication with your name on it and
that's stored in the pharmacies computer
that information then all your
identifiable information is stripped and
sold to a data broker who now has an
unidentified numerical code assigned to
you but they don't know it's you but
this this code is in the computer of
this data broker on the other end you
have a yahoo account yahoo knows a bunch
of identifiable information about your
name your birth date all that sort of
thing yahoo goes through the same
process of stripping that information
out and giving you a unique code then
through a computer through algorithms
they can match those two things up they
can match your prescription records they
can match your online accounts to say ah
this person at this yahoo account saw an
ad and went and filled a prescription
and there let's send a more ads let's
target them so no names are changed but
these unique identifiable codes are
changed in a way that's even worse than
names because there might be a lot of
mark Compton's out there yeah but
there's only going to be one person with
this unique code that they've now
attached to your identity which
companies are involved in this uh yahoo
so anyone who has a yahoo account yahoo
is one of the biggest names everyday
health is another website that does it
then there's some pharmaceutical
companies AstraZeneca Sanofi are a
couple of the big pharmaceutical
companies there's other pharma companies
who would not
deny or you know admit whether or not
they do this so some companies want to
even tell us one company told us that
they used to do this GlaxoSmithKline but
then they found it you know they thought
well you know maybe this is a little on
the borderline here maybe this is
something we don't want to be actually
doing and they stopped doing it Shannon
what are the benefits and what are the
risks of drug makers and Internet
companies joining forces like this well
for drug makers it's great for them I
mean they the marketing has become a lot
more difficult for drug makers in the
past before there was the doctor that
they could really directly market to and
get to the patients that way doctors
have been closing their doors to Pharma
reps saying we don't want to be
associated with you we don't want to
look like we're being influenced by you
so they've kind of been cut off on the
doctor and the web is like this prime
area of marketing that they haven't
gotten into so this is great for the
pharmaceutical business and the
companies doing this can charge a lot of
money hundreds of thousands of dollars
for ad campaigns that use this process
we're talking about called match backs
so they didn't have provider wins the
pharmaceutical company wins now the
patient if you want these ads if you
want to know about all these drugs
that's great if you find it creepy now
that all of a sudden you're getting ads
for you know a sensitive medication I
like maybe an erectile dysfunction drug
or an antidepressant you might not want
that information now popping up on your
web browsers Shannon in your story on
bloomberg.com do you you write that the
international pharmaceutical
Federation's code of ethics requires
that members quote respect and protect
the confidentiality of patient
information this is legal but is it
ethical uh there's a number of privacy
advocates privacy scholars who say no
that they are really upset about this
they do not think that this is
appropriate they think it at the minimum
it should be very clearly disclosed to
people what's going on and for example
in Yahoo's privacy policy they do not
spell out that this process goes on at
all and so it the minimum people should
be informed that this is happening okay
so then it would lead one to believe
that there may be a legislative remedy
to this because obviously the loophole
in the privacy law is cavernous to say
the least
yes HHS the Health and Human Services
they oversee hit by the federal privacy
law for patients when we contacted them
about this they were not aware of the
practice the FDA yes they were not aware
of that the FTC our sources there tell
us this is something they are very
interested in looking into an
investigating so there may very well be
some changes down the road